let's say you have Rush Hour 5 or
whatever and it's dead Bruce Lee and
dead who's the black dude Richard Pryor
Richard Pryor Richard Pryor Bruce Lee
might have been a great movie and they
were around at the same time yeah that'd
be pretty good I got excited somebody
buy the rice to their faces and let's
make it stuff for me personally because
ever since I saw once upon a time in
Hollywood I just see Bruce Lee is a huge
blubbering [ __ ] now you got slammed
dude they were pissed about I mean
they're still pissed about that yeah
that's for sure Madam Quentin
Tarantino's basis for that wasn't based
on real truth nothing was in the whole
movie Brad Pitt had to be a badass right
so he had to beat up the Bruce Lee part
was like come on I still didn't like
that movie I didn't either it was an
awful movie they're made to expose
people who don't understand Cinema so
yeah
does it feel like when you say you don't
like a Quentin movie someone's gonna go
well of course you don't like it yeah
you're not emotional damage yeah you
don't go to groundwork coffee of course
you don't know of course you know you
gotta go to Nick's Cafe